alors je vous explique le sport c'est la
villa corse et par tous ces prix il sait
plus où il est lui lève toi tu poses ton
kebab dépêche bankable on continue nelly
tu prends le ballon et obélix tu passes
ton couscous c'est pas couscous oubliez
tout est beauté spears pour toi tu
m'écoutes croit simon tahrir au caire
car jack tu crois pas l'angoissé de
vivre cette hausse est pas un prénom qui
va s'accrocher aux branches jeune homme
bon et est votre petit manège là on est
motivés je crois que tu t'assois ferrer
diakite chance appartient fait attention
mais toi tu m'enlèves ta perruque
alors il paraît qu'on veut faire des
sports extrêmes à l'intérieur voilà les
5000 soit c'est du basket d'achat
c'est l'essentiel sont les gens qu'on
avance on peut aller du rythme